Nancy is in Orlando hi Nancy how are you
hi I'm fine thanks Dave thank you for
taking my call
sure what's up um I have a question I
make fifty eight thousand a year you're
always saying that people should only
have a monthly payment including
principle taxes and interest in the
amount of 25% of their take-home I only
bring home about three thousand a month
after deductions that would mean I
should only pay 750 a month and I don't
feel that that's possible so what do you
suggest and I currently have a health
and I'm going to put it on the market
but I'm paying 1,500 a month okay
now by take-home pay I mean after taxes
not after you're paying for insurance or
paying for something out of your check
or putting money in a 401k okay because
that take-home does include those
deductions yeah and that's not all going
I'm talking about tanked home pay after
taxes
yes strictly after this cause you're
paying for some insurance you're paying
you're putting money in a 401k and note
because there's no way fifty five turns
into 36 otherwise yeah I bet that's what
had me concerned yeah so you know that's
the number I would use so you know 55
your taxes or 58 I'm sorry let's see you
know you're probably more like $4,000 a
month say about $1,000 a months about
what you need to be spending give or
take that that would be your your real
take-home pay would be more like a
thousand I mean might be more like four
thousand okay all righty you probably
have a thousand going out in insurance
and 401k don't you no not really no no
part of part of my deductions until just
recently included a 401k loan I was
repaying but that's done now but anyhow
today you're coming home with three
thousand dollars out of five yeah yeah
okay where's that going cuz it's not
taxes I'm not sure to be honest they
need to get your check out and find out
where your money is going because that's
what we're talking about cuz your taxes
on that are not going to be over a
thousand dollars a month which means you
got another thousand coming out and
other stuff
some kind and you need to figure out
what that is just so you know what it is
but your take-home pay where you're not
having insurance and 401k and so forth
coming out non-tax things you would have
that now unless you're getting some kind
of huge refund are you getting a big
refund
well I normally get about four thousand
a year time well that's four hundred on
that that's $400 a month of it huh I
said that's that's three to four hundred
dollars a month of it right there okay
yes you're putting in an extra if you
put in an extra $400 a month that's 48
hundred a year yeah I guess I need to do
another w-4 and just declare more
dependents or whatever exactly so that
you don't have a you know a savings
account with the IRS that doesn't pay
interest and they give it back to you in
April right
that's what over deducting is right and
that's four hundred of it we found right
there three or four hundred fifty four
hundred of it and I think the rest of
its probably stuff you just haven't
looked at or something along those lines
but yeah anyway back to your original
discussion somewhere around a thousand
dollars a month is what we're talking
about okay already that'd make more
sense as much yes it does thanks for the
call hey you guys Rachael Cruz here hope
you're enjoying the Dave Ramsey show and
did you know that I have my very own
YouTube channel yes that's right kind of
better
Dave Ramsey channel don't tell them I
said that I'm kidding I'm kidding so
subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you